c'est en kyste ukrainien ou livré bien
des batailles ces derniers mois
les gestes sont mécaniques
leur T72 de l'air soviétique fait le
plein de munitions en quelques minutes
nous les suivons sur leur position de
tir accompagné du commandant de leur
unité
personne est à 25 km environ tenu par
les troupes russes depuis maintenant 8
mois
il a juste sa trajectoire et se prépare
à tirer
notre infanterie se sert d'un drone pour
nous donner des indications
[Musique]
une surveillance aérienne est effectuée
au même moment au-dessus du blindé et
des positions russes prises pour cible
la garantie d'une précision redoutable
pour les temps qui est
l'armée a accepté de nous fournir ces
images une
occasion rare de montrer en temps réel
les points d'impact des tirs ils visent
un village entièrement occupé par les
troupes russes situés à 8 km
la localité est pilonnée par le char que
nous suivons et par d'autres positions
d'artillerie ukrainienne
notre objectif a bien été touché
maintenant il faut continuer et finir le
travail
mais des tirs de riposte de l'artillerie
russe se rapproche
nous nous replions dans un village
abandonné
c'est la route qu'on doit prendre qui
est frappée en ce moment
un hélicoptère ukrainien passe à
proximité
il attaque à son tour les positions
russes
nous profitons d'une accalmie pour
retourner sur la base de cette unité ces
hommes n'ont jamais cessé de se battre
depuis le 24 février
beaucoup d'entre eux défendaient
personne au moment où les Russes ont
pris la ville
pour leur commandant les livraisons
d'armes étrangères sont toujours
insuffisantes
il nous faut des chars modernes des
Abrahams des Leclercs des chiftens
Britanniques avec ça on pourra reprendre
rapidement personne puis la Crimée et
retrouver nos frontières de 2014 et nous
mettrions enfin un terme à ce génocide à
cette destruction de la nation
ukrainienne
l'Ukraine demande sans succès la
livraison de charges occidentaux depuis
le début de l'invasion